So you've got a working prototype, and
you've gotten some feedback from others.
Now all you have to do is
just keep plugging away at it
until all of the bugs are squashed and
your app doesn't crash at any point.
You might even think at this point
you're ready to submit to the app store.
Sorry Charlies, it's actually time for
you to do more user testing.
See, at this point,
you're just too close to your app.
I mean, you know exactly
how it's supposed to work.
And you also know how to
avoid any sticky situations,
however subconsciously
you might be doing it.
I mean, simply put,
you just can't be trusted to
reliably test your app anymore.
And now it's time for,
you guessed it, more user testing!
In addition to your classmates, it's
also a good idea to distribute your app
to your family and
friends, or even better,
a neutral third party who won't be
afraid to give you critical feedback.
But, how do you get these apps to users?
Let's take a look.